bootleg cab show special guest in here
the legendary kevin gates
well i got a question thank you for
having me of course
could i pray first let's go man we do
this of course let's do it
creator and make up the heavens and
earth thank you for all the wonderful
blessings in which you bestowed upon us
in this life and in heaven as the jew
forgive us for all our sins we forget
those who sin against us even the sins
we may have committed knowing and
unknowing
be with each and every brother and
sister in all living species those laws
find incarcerated those free
let anything that i say that's uplifting
to people
come from you and you alone
that anything that i say that's not
uplifting to people come from the
shaytan and me i'd be here responsible
i mean
there it is
you know it's uh the last time i
interviewed you you prayed before the
interview too that was a
time i would
the don't touch me interview but it
wasn't like i think that that was
misinterpreted no i you know what i tell
you yeah you go ahead go ahead like i
understand what you're saying but please
don't touch me again yeah i just
it just was different it's and i'm not
trying to have picks and choosers but
some people
the energy's in alignment other people
the energy is not an alignment and
there's nothing against him he's a great
guy great guy great guy you know what
i'm saying it's just i believe that
maybe my energy was off that day you
know what's interesting about that about
that day was
we did the interview
and after the interview i don't know if
you remember we talked for like an hour
and you played us the album and you were
like man i wish we would have started
the interview now because now i know
y'all and now
you know you step into an unfamiliar
situation
and
it just was it was tense
being that i had just came home i was
yeah you were fresh out i was on
supervised release mm-hmm so i was still
in a different type of mode i was can we
get the mic in front of you if you don't
mind just yeah
i was still in a transitioning period
being
in the box
to
being back in our society
so you know it was still a little
different for me yeah that was that was
um i always cause people always ask me
about that one moment and i'm always
like you know what i tell them i'm like
you know what's crazy is after the
interview ended we hung out and the
energy was amazing amazing yeah and like
you played us the whole album front to
back and we had good talks like it was
it was it was a that was still a it was
i mean i don't be honest with you like
when i look at
old
interviews and old videos of myself i
cringe
like
that's the that was the on drugs kevin
wow
that was the that was the fed
you know unhealthy on drugs
like
i don't know it's beautiful because i
could look at my growth and see it but i
never want to be that person again right
ever in life